last question today's from Vinny Vinny
says this public speaking make you
nervous yeah it kind of does actually I
mean it's funny because on the show we
estimate our daily audience to be about
250,000 250,000 people roughly in a day
across our different platforms and we
just sit here we chat and it's really no
big deal whatsoever does not make me
nervous at all I will sometimes speak to
a college class of 35 or 40 people and
that makes me definitely palpably
nervous and it I guess you know the real
difference is not number of people it's
the number of people it uh that it's
it's the idea that there in the room
with you that I think is the difference
for some reason there's something
different about it yeah I can't explain
it either it's just when their eyes are
locked on you right there's something
happening yeah and I don't know you
might have to ask a neurologist what's
happening you might have to ask someone
who is studying the supernatural what is
happening there right something is
different and over time I definitely get
way less nervous speaking to college
classes in part especially when you know
when I was 24 and I spoke to college
classes or 25 these were essentially my
peers right so there's a sort of very
different dynamic now that I'm 32 when
you said i'm i'm stunned every time i
see 18 year old college freshman I'm
like this is that what I looked like
when i was a freshman in college they
really do look very very young so it
starts to become a sort of different
dynamic where you say would you be
nervous if you spoke to six-year-olds no
i wouldn't be nervous speaking to
six-year-olds not that an 18 year old is
a six year old but they're starts to be
a sort of generational gap which i think
makes it less of a of a dynamic where
you would feel nervous type thing well
as someone who does almost no public
speaking I'm I can't really comment on
that but I will say that I definitely
when when I have multiple eyes on me i
will feel I guess you could say nervous
I guess it is nervousness alright uh if
and if people fall up might be do I have
any techniques to be less nervous not
really I mean once it starts I'm
basically fine you know that's that's
the I just I just tell myself I've done
this many times before and as soon as it
gets going it's going to be fine i am
going to be moderating a panel with some
progressive media people in May in new
york city and i'll have details about
this because it
is going to be open to the public maybe
some of our viewers will join us and
supposedly it's going to be three to
five hundred people I anticipate being
somewhat nervous before that I gave a
speech at a school once to the full
faculty and student body it was like 700
people total that was probably the most
nervous I've been before speech and
interestingly it was a total 360
auditorium where there were people
behind me up on the second floor
mezzanine and something about the setup
it was really stressing me out well I
think if you are part of a panel yeah uh
it's probably easier because moderating
your moderating okay well your
moderating so still the focus isn't
completely on you right but if you are
if the focus is completely on you no one
else is looking at anyone else right no
one else listen anyone else talk then
that I probably amplifies the effect
yeah no doubt about it all right send me
your thoughts on this send me your
techniques and the whole visualizing the
crowd naked I've never really understood
that as a way to not be nervous it does
not hasn't really made sense we have a
fantastic bonus show today you know
it'll be great sign up at david
pakman.com slash membership gonna be
terrific